The sauce, Kevin here, and I haven't had food or drink in days.
I'm so hungry and so thirsty.
And I've got these bagel bites and this bottle of mountain Dew.
If I'm equally hungry and thirsty,
do I eat or drink? Eat, or drink,
eat or drink, eat or drink, eat or drink, eat or drink, eat or drink.
Don't drink, eat or drink.
And if I sit here paralyzed by indecision long enough,
I will die of starvation and dehydration
technically dehydration first. Anyway, that's not good.
This classic decision theory paradox was created in the 14th century
by John brewery,
Don involving a famished donkey who dies from indecision.
And this whole thing is completely irrelevant, absurd,
and has no bearing on our modern sophisticated 21st
century lives, right wrong.
We're faced with one of the most important choices of our time.
Everything hinges on what we decide your future
is at stake. And in this period of dissension, friction,
strife, and everything that's going on,
we need to band together and elect a president
of YouTube. After months of debates and campaigning,
the people have spoken to candidates have emerged the McCobb
internet archeologist Wang and the feculent animation goblin
psychic pebbles.
It is a time for choosing let's meet our candidates.
As your YouTube president.
I promise to restore this website to its former glory days.
It's days of offensive root Tesco,
brand unfriendly wild West chaos,
malicious insults based on intrinsic attributes.
That's what his website was built on. Copyright copyright. Come on,
making fun of this hilarious,
both for freedom and join the Wang gang.
Uh, thank you, Wang. Uh, let's hear from pebbles.
As you're a YouTube president.
I pledge that every utuber with over 1 billion subscribers must compete and
annual no holds barred, Duggar,
dove style battery out where the winner keeps their channel and all the others
are deleted. So I asked you for a vote for fairness,
and to join the cult of pebbles. Uh, you know,
we have a great selection of imported cheeses,
and that's just one of the perks I'm not even going to go on, but yeah,
there's a lot. That's just one fighting.
To the death. Sounds bad,
but I do like cheese.
I don't know who to pick you though, you know, right away,
whether you're in the lawless Wang gang,
or you want to be lured in by the cult of pebbles.
They're so different from each other that the choice is
obvious or you definitely know which one you don't want,
which is good for the candidates. No, no,
it's surprisingly not.
I've got gas. So I'm going to open up a gas station.
Jake's pumping dump gas station already exists near the middle of
town. It's right next to taco bell, obviously.
So I'll open up mine further away. We're selling gas.
As long as the prices are similar,
people are just going to fill up where it's closest.
Jake can have all of these customers and I'll have all these
no problem right wrong.
If the two are far apart and we do pretty much the same thing,
which we do,
we'll be splitting the customers in this distance between us.
So the smaller that distance, the fewer customers,
I lose to the pump and dump.
I get everything on my side of town and I don't lose
anything between our two gas stations. And Hey,
if I run some amazing gas station, sushi promotion,
maybe I can even pull some customers from barely into
Jake's side of town. The further I am away,
the more people I have to convince to choose my
gas station and not his,
this is why McDonald's can have basically the same menu with their own spin.
And even their logos are both primarily yellow and red.
And why fast food places in general are all typically located near
each other.
It's called hoteling is law outlined in the 1929 stability in
competition by economists Harold hotel,
stating that it's rational for two competitors to be as similar as possible
to each other while retaining their own distinct identity.
Cool time for Wang as your YouTube,
I will bring back the five star rating system. Well,
as your YouTube president, the IQ will bring back the star rating system,
but there will be six stars, not five on this issue.
The two candidates are pretty close. There's a difference,
but it's not much hoteling.
Law happens with voting it's in a candidates interest to be pretty similar
to their opponent, to minimize that loss in the middle. Hey,
do you want an Apple or an orange pick one? That's not very hard.
You probably like one fruit more than the other.
So it's a simple choice,
but do you want this Apple or that Apple?
How do you even make that decision?
You base it on the size of the Apple,
the shape of the Apple it's
STEM that's Redskins paradox.
The closer two choices are the harder it is to
choose. So at this point, I really start to analyze, I dig deep.
I stress out over little differences and can even see some that
aren't really there because to make a meaningful choice,
I need there to be a difference.
And now you're thinking I never was like a sheen Northcote Parkinson problem.
And your right in 1957,
seen Northcote Parkinson proposed that the more you analyze something,
the more obsessed you become with the less relevant details and
forget the really big stuff he wrote that the time spent on any
item of an agenda will be in inverse proportion to the sum of money
involved.
Where should I go to college is a question I put some thought into
and it costs tens of thousands of dollars.
What video games should I get is a question I obsess
over and that'll cost 60 bucks at most.
I'm trapped in the tyranny of small decisions.
What economist Alfred econ called that hyper focus on the tiny details that
actually gets you further from the overall outcome you wanted in the first
place.
And then Sayers law knocks on my forehead and says in any dispute,
the intensity of feeling is inversely proportional to the value of the issues
at stake.
Like a couple who's constantly fighting over whether the toilet paper feeds from
the front or the back and never discusses the mounting credit card debt
from buying old PS, one strategy guides off.
EBay, just beat a legend of drag goon, recent lanes.
It who's awesome. So.
How's that a president of YouTube choice coming along now that I'm here in the
weeds, I don't know who to choose.
I'm emotionally invested in figuring it out.
I go deep on less important details and I'm kind of starting to lose
my mind. So, all right. All right. Whoa, wait, how about this baby?
This election is not even about me.
Maybe I want to do what's best for the world around
me. Think of a board family in Texas it's Saturday. Hey,
no one's doing anything.
The dad suggests they all take a trip up to Abilene an hour away because he
thinks the family will enjoy it.
He knows the drive sucks and he'll sweat the whole time.
So he's not too excited, but his family they'll love it.
He asks his wife and she's happy to go because she thinks
the group wants it too. She asks their son and he, yes,
because he doesn't want to disappoint his parents.
Their daughter doesn't want to be the only protest vote.
And at this point she would lose three to one anyway.
So she enthusiastically says yes too.
And that's how a family of four unanimously voted to take a
long, hot trip in a car full of sweat.
And dad's farts that none of them actually wanted to take.
That's Jerry B Harvey's Abilene paradox and voting for what?
No one really wants,
happens a lot in selfless democracies.
But here's my question.
Is that just a function of having only two choices,
Wang or pebbles stay home or go to Abilene.
It's got to get easier when you have more choices, right wrong.
Arrow's impossibility theorem shows us that when voters have three or more
different options,
there's just no way to get exactly the right community wide outcome.
Even if we rank candidate preferences,
we've got Wang and pebbles and we could throw in smarter every day and Lindsay
Ellis and Marquez Brown Lee,
and so young and preferentially ranked them all one through six and we
still would not get the YouTube government we all wanted.
So why should I even bother?
And how much do you or I count anyway,
in 1793, French philosopher,
Marquis de Condorcet wrote that in single stage elections where there are a
great many voters. Each voters influence is very small.
It is therefore possible that the citizens will not be sufficiently
interested to vote. Look at my plate of sand.
One single vote is really the inverse of the Greek sororities
paradox, where you remove grains of sand one by one from him.
Here we go. We're moving brains one at a time.
Rain too. Here we go. Rain.
All right. You know what? This is going to take forever.
Look at what point does it stop being a
heat? At what point does your infinitesimal vote add up
to actually mattering paradox, lightning round.
If a rational voter relies on their self-interest to make their choice,
the costs of that boat are usually greater than the benefits. Anthony Downs,
paradox of voting.
Adding a new state can reduce the number of congressional representatives in
another state or portion in paradox or a state with a fast growing
population can lose representatives to a slow growing state population.
Paradox want to reduce the use of fossil fuels.
Green policies can incentivize a short-term rise in consumption.
Han's Verner, sins.
Green paradox.
It's so hard to make sense.
Of all of this when add up all the logic,
traps and complexities of something that seems so simple,
drink or eat Apple a or Apple B hypothetically,
make my family happy or tell the truth that I don't want to go to Abilene.
And neither do they. The more I think about it,
the less I'm sure.
I know every time we make a choice like Wang, VI,
pebbles, or vote for a real precedent,
we're subject to all of these hidden consequences of decision theory
and mine are different from yours.
You've got to think about all the options, all the scenarios,
all of the contradictions and all the fallacies,
but ultimately it's more important that you
don't get stuck in a cognitive web of indecision,
psyching yourself out from making a choice at all,
or you'll end up staring at bagel bites and mountain Dew
until you're a dead gamer donkey.
Now go to Twitter and vote for your next YouTube president,
chaos or cheese choose wisely. And as always, thanks for watching,
I was going to eat it, but it's freezing cold. So I am going to eat.
I'm just going to heat up.
[inaudible] ah,
greetings cook over here to get the new subscription for thinkers.
It's the curiosity box. It's Vsauce at your door.
Click over here to watch more Vsauce, two more of my videos.
If you want to see my podcast with psychic pebbles, click over there,
click something, make a choice. Here we go.
Bye.